was that a lot of people a lot of people
who like DeSantis a lot of people on my
side of this operation have been saying
DeSantis needs to go and start doing
some of the corporate press knowing
they're going to lie about him knowing
that they lie about everything but you
got to get in the game you got to do
more viral moments you got to fight back
you got to figure out new ways of being
in combative interviews uh not just
beyond with the friendlies I think
that's an absolutely uh Fair criticism
so DeSantis finally yesterday went on
CNN for the first time as a presidential
candidate went on Jake Tapper Jake is
obviously a Democrat it's you know he
doesn't say it outwardly but obviously
is they got into it on a bunch of stuff
we're going to show you some clips with
that and then Donald Trump last night
fresh off this this new ridiculous
January 6 indictment uh went on Hannity
another town hall with Hannity he does
these every few months this is after he
skipped the big Blaze Forum with Tucker
I would have loved to have seen him
there I think that would have been good
for him and I think it would have been
good for everybody and Tucker and all of
us anyway he went to Hannity we're going
to compare and contrast and uh we are
going to talk about a couple other
things that are happening culturally
right now and then I believe we have
some humor loaded into the program today
as well so it's a big one for you and
before we get to all that let me talk to
you guys about gravity to Fire Shoes how
much is it worth to not feel pain every
step you take from walking the dog to
running the kids from school to practice
it all takes a toll well you need to
check out gravity to Fire Shoes whether
you're wearing them on the job or you or
to get to your daily step count these
gravity to fire shoes are revolutionary
walking and running in normal shoes
creates shock waves that course through
your feet knees and hips forcing the
body to absorb as much as a thousand
pounds of harmful impact with every step
gravity to buy your shoes are clinically
shown to relieve knee pain in a
double-blind study with Olive View UCLA
Medical Center and published in the
Journal of American podiatric podiatric
that's a word I guess not oh podiatric
podiatric all right uh Medical
Association participants experienced 85
percent less knee pain here's the deal
guys try a pair risk-free for 60 days
and experience the difference they can
make in your life it's the most powerful
shock absorption system ever put into a
shoe buy a pair today and save 15 with
free returns and easy exchanges you have
nothing to lose visit g d e f i uh sorry
no
g-d-e-f-y.com use code Reuben for 15
discount on your first order test a pair
risk-free and experience the difference
they can make in your life visit g d e f
y.com
promo code Reuben for 15 percent
discount off your first order and now
back to me so uh many of you probably
noted that yesterday's show yesterday's
Reuben report we were we were live at 2
p.m not our normal 11 A.M eastern time
and the reason for that was I was over
at the valutainment studios in Fort
Lauderdale for the Patrick Bet David
podcast uh Patrick and I got into he's
uh he does mostly business stuff on his
show but it's sort of everything's
colliding right business entertainment
politics these things are all colliding
into one thing uh and he also is a guy
much like me who Moved himself his
family several companies to Florida
during covid and we got into what's
going on uh in the Republican race
specifically uh I mentioned him up top
something that I said to you guys on the
show the other day that there were kind
of two things that you're looking for in
a candidate that I think you should be
looking for let's put it that way number
one do you roughly agree with the
policies right does he roughly this he
or her do they roughly make sense
economically whatever the social issues
you are care about foreign policy
borders Etc does that kind of fit with
what you like maybe not everything but
kinda and the second thing do you think
they can accomplish it and I think we
should mostly be focusing on that
because what they purport to believe or
not is kind of irrelevant if they can't
get any of it done anyway Patrick and I
got into what's going on here and we're
going to show you two clips of that and
then we'll get to DeSantis and Trump and
a bunch more here we go
do you think we are seeing and
witnessing where the whole idea of what
Nixon uh uh lost to John F Kennedy years
ago because Nixon was a very qualified
candidate more qualified than John F
Kennedy Nixon was essentially a Ron
DeSantis for forget the Watergate
example just set that part aside where
Nixon had to learn how to go be a little
bit more of a showman yeah more
presentable and he had to go work with
some people behind closed doors do you
think that's a fair criticism that Ron
is getting in do you think that's going
to hurt him or do you think no I think
it's irrelevant he can see he still has
a shot well you know last time we sat on
this very stage which was probably about
four months ago uh you brought that up
that there's a marketing issue with
DeSantis to me that's and I'll repeat
what I said that time and then I'll give
you a new Twist on it to me that's a
very solvable problem I think what you
want out of a candidate are two things
you want they basically does this guy
roughly believe in the things that I
believe in politically are we do we have
enough stuff that we kind of agree on
that I can support this guy and then do
you think that this guy can accomplish
it that's that I think is the bigger one
now because I think we have a lot of
people who say the right things but can
they actually do it now in my estimation
obviously DeSantis checks those two
boxes okay I suppose I just led into
that clip with exactly what I said in
that clip so you get the point that is
what I think is the important thing what
what Patrick is focused on and he's a
he's a marketing business guy mostly his
argument so far is that he likes all of
the policies of DeSantis again moved his
family here companies here all of that
stuff thriving in the Free State of
Florida what he's been arguing for about
a month and a half now is that since the
DeSantis launch there hasn't been a good
enough marketing machine behind it to
catch fire I can't really argue with
that right like you can just at the end
of the day uh is is the thing exploding
the way I would want it to explode
probably not I believe as I said
yesterday that in the tortoise and hair
the hair usually wins but we shall see
but there might be some marketing issue
there which is what he Likens to the
Nixon versus Kennedy debate from what
was at you know like 62 or so uh when
Nixon you know he's up there and he
looks kind of gruff and sweaty and
murmur and Kennedy was very telegenic
and pleasant and nice to listen to and
all of those things so let's get to one
more clip from the pbd podcast as we
unpacked all of this stuff a bit more in
terms of what DeSantis could do to
actually fix that if you believe it's an
issue is there some level of a marketing
thing well look he has not done your
show he absolutely should do your show
so I don't know where you guys are at
internally with that but he should uh
you know just yesterday I think they
announced that he's doing Megan Kelly
finally now she's been very critical of
him partially because he has not done
her show it's a great move to go on that
show uh he's going on uh Jake Tapper
today uh at four yeah so so that is an
interesting moment he go you know he's
basically his position with the
mainstream media has basically been you
guys lie about everything I'm not going
to play your game as opposed to Trump
where it's you guys lie about everything
I'll constantly play your game but now
he's realizing okay I gotta get in on
that so we'll see what happens with him
and Tapper I would love to see the guy
go on Rogan he should he should just say
offhand he should say hey I'll do Rogan
why not why wouldn't I do that
three-hour thing not just the the
20-minute thing he should sit down with
those harpies on The View and let them
say all of the crazy BS none okay I
don't need to analyze myself so let's
dive right into it uh yesterday the
governor went on Jake Tapper and uh
Tapper went after him sort of or opened
it up by saying you know this this thing
ain't going that well uh to which
desantis's reply was
so this issue gets into the the state of
the race because some of your supporters
are disappointed that your campaign has
yet to catch fire the way they would
want in terms of polling uh one
Republican pollster one who is
sympathetic to you I was asking her
about your campaign and she said she
thought the issue was you bumped up at
the beginning because voters Republican
voters saw you as a more electable
conservative like Trump like you Trump
without the baggage but then they say as
you go further and further to the right
on some of these divisive social issues
that could alienate moderate Suburban
moms Etc Republican voters see you as
less and less electable what do you say
to that analysis I don't think that's
true I mean the proof is in the pudding
I mean I took a state that had been a
one-point State and we won it by 20
percentage points 1.5 million votes uh
our bread and butter were people like
Suburban moms we're leading a big
movement for for parents rights to have
the parents be involved in education
school choice get the indoctrination out
of schools of course there's bread and
butter issues that matter too inflation
more Economic Opportunity Florida's
economy is ranked number one of all 50
states we've worked hard to make that
happen crime you see crime in all these
different communities that is now even
going into suburbs in some areas so it's
interesting because the the interview
did not get too combative I actually
would have liked probably to have seen
it got a little more combative like
DeSantis literally just out of nowhere
be like you know Jake how many times all
due respect your question how many times
did you call it don't say gay on this
program how many times has your network
done that because you know the word gay
wasn't in there but okay those fireworks
didn't happen but it's interesting when
I when I called Jake Tapper a Democrat
or a Democrat activist or an activist as
opposed to a journalist you can see the
way he's framing that question he says
well there's this polar who says this
except DeSantis by as his answer
correctly pointed out by focusing on the
social issues which are deeply important
to moderates and mothers who don't want
their kids sexualized and all of these
things DeSantis then won by a landslide
so the framing of the question and
that's one of the hardest things to get
sort of the average non-political person
to understand they think people just sit
down and everything's kind of equal but
Jake takes everything from a position a
leftist position DeSantis when you say
he's been to the right on these social
issues uh well is it is it far right or
even to the right to say that kids
shouldn't be sexualized the kids
shouldn't be learning about I don't know
hardcore anal sex while in third grade
is that like a crazy position is that a
position of the right in which case I
guess most of us are far right but it
continued because that was tapper's sort
of main push Point here that DeSantis is
just too far right
I don't think that's the reason I think
the reason is is I was getting a lot of
media attention at the time coming off
the victory I had to do my job as
Governor with my legislative session and
we had a great legislative session we
did a lot of great things actually
things that are appealed to huge
majorities of the of the population so I
think that that analysis is wrong
um but I had to do that and so I was
basically taking fire really non-stop
since then because a lot of people view
me as a threat I think the left views me
as a threat because they think I'll beat
Biden and actually deliver on all this
stuff and then of course people that
have their allegiances within the
allegiances in the Republican side you
know okay to me that's a clean clear
answer I say what I'm gonna do I'm doing
it
I'm going to be better than Trump I can
beat Biden I'm running the way that I
think I should run then your opinions on
that are are completely up to you but I
think the next part of this is you can't
just be on the defense with these people
you have to lay out what that positive
vision is right you have to do something
that's aspirational for people the
aspirational part of desantis's core
message of course was during covet where
when this very state that I'm sitting in
right at this moment uh became the
beacon of freedom for the entire world
uh here's DeSantis laying out more of
what that Vision looks like and then the
second thing I would say is this country
needs to have a debate about the
country's future if I'm the nominee
we'll be able to focus on President
Biden's failures and I'll be able to
articulate a positive vision for the
future I don't think it serves us good
to have a presidential election focused
on what happened four years ago uh in
January and so I want to focus on
looking forward I don't want to look
back I do not want to see him I hope he
doesn't get charged I don't think it'll
be good for the country but at the same
time I've got to focus on looking
forward and that's what we're going to
do okay so we'll get more we'll get two
more on the Trump indictment and
desantis's response to the indictment
and some of what the surrogates were
doing and the lying and selectively
edited videos and a whole bunch more but
there he's saying we have we have to put
some of this stuff behind us and we have
to start blazing a new Trail I want to
show you one more clip from the
interview for now which was that a lot
of people I know not you guys but a lot
of sort of NPC type people who watch
MSNBC in the view they think that
Florida is a Bastion of hatred they
think that we hate gay people and we
hate black people and we are just
xenophobic bigots and all of the other
buzzwords and of course Jake had to ask
him about that
in trans adults in the U.S what are
their lives and the lives of the people
who love and support them going to be
like under a DeSantis Administration
look in the military it's all about the
mission first so there's a whole bunch
of reasons uh why you focus on Mission
first people's individuality it does
take you you do have to check that at
the door and that's not the only example
there's a whole host of other examples
so I think the military culture is
unique in terms of that now in terms of
the larger issue the question is is you
know what role does someone that's a man
have in women's activities even if they
conceive themselves to be a woman I
think it's wrong to have men compete in
women's sports I understand some of
those men conceive of themselves
differently but it's not fair to the
girls who are competing it's not fair to
the women athletes the swimmers who lost
that National Championship to the pen
swimmer I mean they've been training too
so I don't think it's good for that and
I think having things like locker rooms
where they're having to share with
somebody who's of the opposite sex you
know I think is wrong so I would respect
everybody but what I wouldn't do is turn
Society upside down to be able to
accommodate which is a very very small
percentage of the population guys I want
to be clear that is as good a clean
nuanced answer as you possibly
can have related to all of this I hate
the letter thing LGBT nonsense he's
delineating clearly the difference
between say if you're a member of the
military why it complicates things
because mission is first above
individuality right and he is a former
member of the Navy okay so that's that's
one thing right there right then number
two he's talking about
biological men and women sports the
thing that we all know to be true right
that biologically men are generally
stronger and bigger and better at sports
than women it's just reality show me the
chick who's ready to play in the NBA she
doesn't exist every single NBA player
would be the MVP in the WNBA we all know
it and then thirdly he's saying but I
will treat everyone with respect you
don't upend Society for the minority you
want to respect minorities right you
want to give them equality under the law
so he's not saying jail trans people
he's not saying they can't be in
relationships he's not saying they can't
be married or any of those things he's
saying you just don't upend everything
normal everything sensible everything
that we've put to bed in the past in the
name of the new minority hysteria of the
day and we all know that's true and
unfortunately that's what we've at least
the the modern left has been doing with
virtually everything so now let's move
on to Trump a little bit and I want to
give him a fair Shake too uh Trump went
on Hannity last night they did another
one of these Town Halls they seem to be
doing them about once every month or so
and Hannity asked Trump about the Deep
State and whether he effectively dealt
with it last time and kind of what he
would do going forward if he becomes
president again
you knew you rely on other politicians
to give you answers and you find out
that they are rhinos or they gave you
bad advice so we had some that weren't
good but when you think Comey had a term
he had many years left in that term I
said this guy's bad news I realized that
very early very early in the
administration I fired him and it was
wild that's when we found out all of the
corruption had I not fired Comey you
wouldn't know any of the things that you
were talking about you think they would
have destroyed you well they were trying
to take me out yeah they were trying to
take me out I mean it was like a coup it
was like a coup had I not you know it's
very interesting some people that are
very smart that you know very well
said when I did it oh that was a mistake
that was a mistake you're going to cause
now they say it was the greatest
instinctual move they've ever seen
because Comey was a very bad guy and
Comey LED that group of thugs in there
and they were doing a number they were
it's very dishonest it's years and years
of putting in people Democrats and
rhinos and other people but putting them
into office and we got rid of a lot of
them but we're going to get rid of a lot
more a lot more because you have some
bad okay I want to give Trump credit
first before I even analyze anything
there he's saying something actually
very honest at the beginning of this
which is that you get there and then you
have a little time to figure out who the
good guys and the bad guys are right I
referenced it yesterday that he was a
New York City real estate guy and
branding and marketing guy and TV host
for you know decades before this so
getting to the DC swamp I actually Grant
him a very very long leash on figuring
out how deep the swamp goes who are the
swamp members and all of those things I
think that that's absolutely uh worth
mentioning what's interesting there is
you know he's saying you know I got rid
of Comey uh but of course he replaced
him with Christopher Ray and the bass
basically hates Christopher Ray and
Christopher Ray was in essence as much a
part of the swamp as anybody but okay
I'll take his word for it that he has
learned some things and that he would do
a better job next time I thought it was
worth jumping back to something from
about two weeks ago you may remember
when Trump was on Fox news with Brett
Baer and he asked him the same thing
about the Deep State and would he be
able this time to hire the right people
because the track record kinda isn't
there okay in 2016 you said that I'm
going to surround myself with only the
best and most serious people well I did
do that and we had a tremendous look we
had the best economy we've ever had this
town has ever seen your vice president
Mike Pence is running against you yeah
your ambassador to the United Nations
Nikki Haley she's running against you
your former Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said he's not supporting you you
mentioned National Security adviser John
Bolton he's not supporting you either
you mentioned attorney general Bill Barr
uh says you shouldn't be president again
I calls you the consummate narcissist
and troubled man you recently called and
borrow a gutless pig your second defense
secretary is not supporting you called
you irresponsible this week you and your
White House called your white house
chief of staff John Kelly weak and
ineffective and born with a very small
brain you called your acting white house
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney a born
loser you called your first Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson dumb as a rock and
your first defense secretary James
Mattis the world's most overrated
General you called your White House
Press secretary Kayla Nanny milk toast
and multiple times you've referred to
your transportation secretary Elaine
Chao as Mitch McConnell's China loving
wife so
why did you hire all of them
like there's a lot there for some reason
the one that made us all laugh the
gutless pig one just seems funny because
it's like the type of thing like there's
just no chance he said that to his face
like you're a gutless pig it's like what
you just say like so stupid
um also most people by the way just for
the record scientifically most people
are born with a small brain the brain
grows over a series of for about what 18
20 years your brain is going to grow if
you if you are born with a giant brain
you've got a major problem so that's
just a sidebar but anyway it's up to you
like joking aside it's up to you to
decide okay the track record like again
I gave him a lot of credit for not fully
understanding the game learning about
the game and again I'm saying perhaps he
would be much better at the game this
time but I wanted to show you that other
clip because it's like the track record
simply is not good I want to show you
one other clip uh from the Hannity uh
Town Hall last night because chump this
is a really bizarre one help me work
through this one I'm gonna try to
analyze it as honestly as I can as I
always do Trump had some very strong
praise for for Chinese president Xi
Jinping
I will tell you that but think of
President XI Central Casting brilliant
guy you know when I say is brilliant
everyone says oh that's terrible you
call it oh he runs 1.4 billion people
with an iron fist smart brilliant
everything perfect there's nobody in
Hollywood like this smart brilliant
everything perfect and he runs 1.4
billion people
that's an awful lot of credit you're
giving a guy that has a society that's
going through this
[Music]
other people
thank you foreign
[Music]
running everything perfect 1.4 billion
people now you may go well he's just
saying he's smart and Brilliant because
he's able to do that Trump wouldn't do
that but then the question the next
question would be well okay if he didn't
learn the lessons of the swamp if he
didn't bring in the right people what's
to stop the swamp from forcing him to do
that even if it's him that doesn't want
to do that or whatever the authoritarian
type thing is but that he admires
someone who can run a country of that
many people in in such an obviously
horrific way but Trump admires the
success of that personally I think that
is a problem to some degree I want to
show you one other thing that happened
related to all the political nonsense of
of yesterday because of course the
backdrop of all of this is that Trump
got another nonsensical indictment and I
have no problem defending him on all of
these indictments and this is all crazy
BS and it's because he's running for
president and everything else there you
go cards on the table but he gets
indicted and then a video a 14 second
video of later in the day
well the indictment was two days ago but
then yesterday a 14 second edited video
of DeSantis responding to the Trump
indictment was spread by virtually every
single Trump surrogate and trump-related
account online they were all sharing a
14 second video implying that DeSantis
did not was not strong enough against
the indictment I want to show you the 14
second video this was spread it has been
seen hundreds of thousands if not
millions of times 14 seconds so you knew
even before I saw the video I was like
14 seconds it's obviously selectively
edited hundreds of thousands if not
millions of times and listen to the way
they made it sound like DeSantis was
responding to the Trump indictment
difference between being brought up on
criminal charges and and doing things
like for example
um I think it was shown how he was in
the white house and didn't do anything
while things were going on he should
have come out more forcefully of course
that okay so the Trump Camp I mean I'm
telling you virtually every surrogate he
has I don't have to name the names but
virtually everyone he's got online many
of whom I've had on this show uh were
sharing that clip and the implication
was this was Trump's fault he didn't do
anything he was sitting at the White
House now I want to show you the
unedited version of that video this is
from a reporter by the name of Meg
Canard she was with the AP she was a
little bit further back in that room
brought up on criminal charges and and
doing things like for example
um I think it was shown how he was in
the white house and didn't do anything
while things were going on uh he should
have come out more forcefully of course
that but to try to criminalize that
that's a diff that's a different issue
entirely and I think that we we want to
be in a situation where you know you
don't have one side just constantly
trying to put the other side in jail and
and that unfortunately is is uh what
we're seeing now do you see how
fundamentally different those two clips
are and of course the full clip never
goes as viral as the edited clip he's
saying now you may disagree with him
when he's saying yeah Trump could have
said more you may disagree with that and
that's that's an opinion whether Trump
could have said more or anything else he
did say you know be peaceful and all
that but that's an opinion his very next
sentence is you should not be
criminalizing this and his very next
sentence after that is we in essence we
cannot have selective Justice where we
only go after one side how much more can
we possibly ask for in a clear cogent
way and I think it's important to play
that clip I'm sure I'm going to get
plenty of hate for it and probably have
a bunch of people turn on me over it but
I think it's important because if this
is you know this is the information war
that we are left with right we are we
are in the midst of a matrix style
information War where selectively added
Clips can be put out and and the truth
it's much harder the truth runs slower
than than the quick hit of dopamine that
you get when you think you can get the
other guy and that this is a major major
problem anyway now I want to jump over
to the corporate press because CNN has
been covering the Trump January 6th
indictment we don't even know what the
full extent of the indictment is I think
they're going to have a hell of a time
proving that he incited a riot but okay
let's put that aside for a moment here
is CNN's Dana Bash with ever insightful
information on the Trump arrest
turns out even Jack Smith can't resist a
five dollar footlong that's according to
what we see right there new and
exclusive CNN video of the special
council at Subway declining though to
respond to reporter's questions about
today's big news a Target letter sent to
the former president of the United
States CNN's Evan Perez was there trying
to track down the special counsel I
won't ask you all of the uh less
important things about what he got and
yeah how he paid and all that but but
what is important is the imagery here
they clearly wanted us to see him uh and
and that image to be very different from
what we saw in the president former
president's post with which is that he's
a a deranged individual
we're going to mostly focus on the
sandwich and what this guy ate six inch
foot long did he get lettuce how much
mustard did he have on and also he's the
range by the way you know the guys
completely completely the way they frame
and by the that was exclusive video of
CNN my God that's incredible CNN had a
man standing outside a Subway holy sheep
but it continued it wasn't just
Dana Bash I'm fairly certain this is her
husband can you Google this real quick
is Dana Bash married to John King I'm 99
sure the answer is yes they're gonna
google it while we show you John King
also also analyzing what Jack Smith had
for lunch
and just one last point
Jack Smith remember when the classified
documents Target letter when Trump
announced that there's a lot of
commentary it was Jack Smith making a
mistake here is he leaving this all to
Donald Trump and then they release the
indictment and we all said wow wow we
read it we saw the documentation we saw
the level of detail Jack Smith going to
Subway today is a message to Donald
Trump Donald Trump tries to intimidate
people he tries to bully people he tries
to scare you away that was Jack Smith
with no words and a simple five dollar
Sub in his hand saying I'm here I'm not
going to yeah the imagery was uh was
intentional and spoke volume it really
is all right first off we did a little
Googling
apparently Dana abash and John King were
married they are now divorced let's just
put that aside it's funny that they're
still working together on CNN is what it
is uh that is some of the dumbest
analysis I've ever heard in my entire
life he honestly believes and they sit
there and they agree with him that
somehow Jack Smith having lunch I mean
the guy just decided to go for lunch
that that was to send a message to
Donald Trump like you see I'm so calm
and cool and collected about this
indictment that I can get a five dollar
six inch Subway sandwich okay that is
and they they look at him as if that is
a sensible thing to say that is any
bearing to do with reality now I
actually do believe it might be
coordinated because why was CNN standing
outside the very Subway that the guy was
going into are they are they tracking
him all day like a CNN tracking the
prosecutor all day long to follow him I
mean that seems a little weird but uh
that really sent him he would have sent
a message to Donald Trump if he would
have gone to Orange Julius in the mall
and been sucking down one of those gross
orange things like sea orange man I got
you and I'm gonna suck you dry that
would have been something by going to
Subway all he's proving is that he
wasn't near a Jersey Mike's because
Jersey Mike's is obviously way better
than Subway everyone knows that
but if you think that's stupid then you
probably do I'd like to show you
something even stupider Whoopi Goldberg
on The View
turns out even Jack Smith can't resist a
five dollar Footloose bothering me more
I'm sorry about all of this you know the
the young person that the young man they
got for Espionage recently yeah he's do
you know that he's demanding to be
treated exactly the same way as Trump
was he wants to be yes he wants to be
able to go home yeah and do everything
and that's the thing for me that is most
egregious
nobody goes home and no one should be
above nobody nobody is above the law you
should not be walking you should
actually be in the building right that
has the bars on it both of you
okay the kid that she's talking about is
that kid from about what was that about
six weeks ago or so who leaked some
classified documents in a Discord group
and now he is under arrest and we can
have an honest discussion about whether
he should be arrested right now or out
on bail or anything else uh but what
what Whoopi wants is just because Donald
Trump is accused of something right just
because a D.A whether it's Alvin Bragg
up in New York or it's this Jack Smith
guy just because they basically hand the
indictment that Donald Trump should
automatically be in jail and then all of
the harpies agree and all of the
audience agrees and do you realize how
dangerous that would be if every time
someone is accused of something if we
automatically throw them in jail until
it can be proven do you think that might
be a problem do you think that might be
against due process yes yes you do okay
good now to televised mental institution
known as MSNBC they had historian
presidential historian Michael beschlas
on and uh he thinks Trump's on his way
to becoming a dictator yep that's right
the guy who's under indictment for like
87 things and four billion counts of
this and that he's the dictator
you know as Lawrence O'Donnell said uh
Michael beschlas
Donald Trump holds the ultimate
incentive for her meaning he becomes
president Clarence Thomas retires to
permanently vacation with his
billionaire friends who by the way
probably won't want to take him anywhere
anymore because he didn't give him
anything anymore and she gets on the
Supreme Court in her late 30s and then
she had there's no incentive for her to
behave herself if she's Maga she can
Maga and there's nothing we can do about
it well and the other thing is we have
to ask the question just as Josh was
saying why did Donald Trump choose this
moment to tell the American people that
he will become a dictator if elect
did Donald Trump tell the people he'll
become a dictator if elected do we
Phoenix did we drop the clip on that one
the Donald Trump I'm going to be a
dictator clip did Brock are you uh
you're on the computer a lot did we ever
see the Donald Trump I'm going to become
a dictator clip mm-hmm
and we we try we're doing the best we
can over here these people are
absolutely nuts but it continues with
this specialist guy who's supposed to be
again he's supposed to be a presidential
historian right he's supposed to give
perspective related to previous
administrations and the personalities
and behind the scenes what makes a
president and an Administration go and
all of that stuff but he's mostly a
Democrat activist and if you don't
believe me here he is on both Donald
Trump and Ron DeSantis Iran DeSantis
actually offers a very good warning
about what happens in a second Trump
term with somebody who's learned his
lessons instead of just being a
bloviator that goes to Twitter when he's
angry Rod DeSantis is actually giving
him perfect example so this is how you
crush businesses this is how you
intimidate CEOs again I I was talking
talking this past weekend the Republican
from uh from that that that's worked for
the Republican party for a generation
who said
the status is the free state of Florida
is a joke idea this person said I deal
with CEOs every day who are petrified
petrified that Ron DeSantis will notice
them and they're keeping their heads
down they're not doing it because they
know he has the ability to use the power
of the centralized state to crush them
or to make their lives miserable
right and you've got the front runner of
the Republican Party Donald Trump the
number two candidate by polls Ron
DeSantis or DeSantis or whatever it is
they're both fascists they both want
authoritarianism in America
we try to get Michael bachelson on the
show I want to have him emailed
absolutely today what an embarrassing
pathetic human being he is they're
fascists Donald Trump who's now under
sham indictments is the fascist Ron
DeSantis who fought corporations working
with governments
against the will of the people he's the
fascist he was fighting fascism you
and Joe and Joe Scarborough who's
just you guys get it with Joe
Scarborough he just makes it up the idea
that that CEOs are afraid to come to
Florida right now Florida's economy is
booming we've basically taken all of
Silicon Valley and moved it here the
amount of major money makers and the
people the movers and the Shakers
including guys like Donald Trump who
have moved down to Florida where there
are no state income taxes where we have
friendly policies related to regulation
and your ability to build a business
here and live a full fully actualized
thriving life everything they say it's
not just that there are lies they're
they're 180 lies only designed to
confuse you and speaking of 180 lies
only designed to confuse you let me say
something very controversial right now
if you're going through puberty as a boy
you're going to have a male puberty
experience that if you're going through
puberty as a girl you're going to have a
girl female puberty experience you might
go Dave what kind of segue is that what
could you possibly be doing next well
here's dick Levine our favorite Admiral
dick Levine who has interviewed a day or
two ago being asked just to show you how
crazy these people are everything they
say is not just a lie a lie would be one
thing we could put a lie in a pocket and
we could get rid of it everything they
do is a massive 180 smack you in the
face with a pie lie that's what
they do here's
This Woman This Man oh God I almost did
it you see you see what happened here
this guy this guy
is just watch the video just watch the
video
what would you say to folks who think
that they're being reasonable by saying
why can't children just wait till
they're 18. the adolescence is hard and
puberty is hard what if you're going
through the wrong puberty what if you
inside feel that you are female but now
you're going through a male puberty not
he should be fired immediately you
cannot go through the wrong puberty your
body is your body when you are of a
certain age if you wish to dress
whichever way you want and put lipstick
on and all that that's just fine
you cannot go through the wrong puberty
the fact that this person has anything
to do with the health of anyone and that
this guy we've shown you the video has
repeatedly said that he is thrilled that
he did not transition when he was young
because his two children that he has
that he was the father to never I
suppose purports to be the mother that
he those are the biggest joys in his
life and that's what he's trying to
steal from 13 year old kids
well we have an editing machine over
here in the studio and we put together a
little something we're going to show you
the same clip with a little twist I
think you're going to enjoy
what would you say to folks who think
that they're being reasonable by saying
why can't children just wait till
they're 18. the adolescence is hard and
puberty is hard what if you're going
through the wrong puberty what if you
inside feel that you are female but now
you're going through a male puberty what
you've just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things I have ever heard
at no point in your rambling incoherent
response were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought
everyone in this room is now Dumber for
having listened to it
I award you no points
and may God have mercy on your soul
that's Billy Madison Peak Adam Sandler I
think around 1995 if I'm not mistaken if
I had a nickel for every time that I got
stoned in college and watched that movie
I'd have a small fortune but these
people lie about everything which is a
perfect Segway we're nailing the Segways
today Karin Jean-Pierre how is she going
to tackle climate change well they're
doing it because of the inflation
reduction act what now and we're doing
everything that we can to tackle the
root causes of climate change this is
why the inflation reduction Act is so
important
oh the inflation reduction act so by
printing a whole bunch of money that
doesn't really exist thus depressing the
value of the dollar we are going to
somehow attack the root cause of climate
change
okay
okay I should have drank before Today's
Show I really should have uh so all
right guys what do we got to do here we
have to expunge these people from the
national conversation they can live in
their alternate World they can be
citizens of the United States but they
should be mocked they should be they
they shouldn't have anything to do with
any of our lives right because they what
they do it's not just that they lie
about everything and that they're wrong
about everything and they accuse you of
all of these things when you start
making inroads as DeSantis has done for
example when you start doing things
right in a flourishing Florida and you
remove wokeness and you get ESG out of
the institutions and things start
working then they lie and they trick you
or they trick certain people to think
that what you're doing is not good here
is former South Carolina state
representative Now CNN analysts bakari
sellers explaining why fighting wokeness
is just the wrong it's just wrong it's
just not in touch with America why would
Americans care if their sons are having
their wines cut off
it's completely out of touch with what
most Americans are feeling you know Joe
Biden is out here talking about
bidenomics and his disconnect is trying
to make sure that my Dynamics meets
people in their pockets wopeness or
whatever Ron DeSantis and Nikki Haley
and everybody else want to say is so far
away from the average everyday American
these people who are working in this as
you can probably hear in the background
working on this hotel across the street
they're not worried about wokeness
they're worried about insurance they're
worried about making sure that they're
you know that their pocketbooks are
filled they're not worried about
somebody being super woke in whatever
aspect of the government it is and so
that is my point to uh Ron DeSantis he's
running against this Ferry he's running
against an imagine an imagination but at
least Donald Trump is running on
policies that I disagree with but he's
run on before which he can articulate
helps strengthen some part of the
economy so that's the difference all
right first off he's doing the quiet
part out loud thing he's showing you
that as a leftist progressive activist
pretending to be a journalist or
whatever he is he's telling telling you
that he wants Donald Trump to run
because Ron DeSantis is the real threat
so sometimes they do that thing
accidentally when they pull the curtain
that's one thing secondly everything he
said there's complete nonsense our
economy is actually flourishing here in
Florida despite the inflation reduction
act and all of those things we have the
largest influx of people that have ever
been here buildings are going up left
and right you guys get it all of the
amount of Tourism set a record in the
first half of the year I'm sure 2023
we'll figure we'll figure as the best
tourism in the history of Florida all of
that you you guys get all that stuff but
also this this notion that people don't
care about the woke stuff that they
don't care about their children being
taught all the sex stuff all the race
stuff and all that is complete nonsense
and again you only have to look at the
way that the guy crushed it in the last
election to know that the results like
don't don't it doesn't matter what you
think about the policy where do people
leave and where do they come and what
happens in the elections uh that happen
in that place well the guy won by
freaking 20 points uh here's DeSantis
one more clip from that Tapper interview
explaining exactly why fighting wokeness
matters hopefully bakari sellers will
check out this clip so I hear you
recruitment without question is a
problem the Army did this survey uh I'll
give you a copy of it if you want they
haven't released it but I got my hands
on a copy and it looked at it surveyed
people I think 16 to 28 barriers to
service and Beyond the ones such as
don't want to die don't want to be
injured don't want to be away from my
family the biggest issues were the
number two issue women in racial or
ethnic minorities are discriminated
against in the Army wokeness is listed
here but it's only it's only number nine
um so that would suggest that wokeness
is not as big well but I think there's
an issue about like not everyone really
knows what wokeness is I mean I've
defined it but a lot of people who rail
against wokeness can't even Define it
and so I think it's a sense of you know
this is not something that's that's
holding true to the core martial values
that make the military unique uh and I
can tell you the veterans you don't have
to look far and wide go to a VFW Hall go
to an American Legion there's huge
amount of concern about the direction
that the military is going with all this
and we just know that's true you don't
even have to go to a VFW Hall to see
that like we know that every time you
see those ads for the military and every
time you see the videos that are leaked
out and they've got a bunch of guys
dressed as girls and drag queen story
hours at military bases and all of this
nonsense and that military recruitment
is now way low but what Jake wants to do
is he doesn't really want you to think
about that that's number nine there's a
whole bunch of other stuff as if you
can't do two things at once so of course
there is a huge amount of concern over
the direction of the country and the guy
that they seem to all be focused on
hating the most uh is the guy that's
actually doing the most to fight that
very thing so we have to figure out who
who is the enemy what are the bad set of
ideas and how do we defeat them and now
to end the show we will give you a
throwback clip old school
former prime minister of England
Margaret Thatcher summarizing who the
enemy actually is
the essence of socialism is that you
surrender quite a bit of power over your
own life to the state where we all do
that to some extent but of course it
went much further
uh you pay very high taxes and they wish
to um take even higher taxes because
they think that politicians can spend
money better than the people can spend
it the more you take away the less there
is for Private Industry and that's where
the creation of wealth comes so you have
to establish very clear limits on the
role of government and really you'll
know politicians I think should
sometimes just be a little bit more
modest about their abilities than they
are we can't run everything and we
shouldn't try
you know when the state does everything
for you it'll soon take everything from
you
you will then have no basis for personal
freedom
political freedom
nor economic freedom it's brilliant it's
true and it's actually quite chilling as
Joe Scarborough
calls the people who fight the collusion
between government and corporations
fascists
that's the truth right there that's the
truth the more that you ask for the
government the more that you demand the
government do for you the more that you
become a slave to that government the
more you become a slave to the machine
we have a couple people right now in
this country who are trying to fight
that and we have a whole corporate press
and a big Tech monstrosity and a bunch
more that are trying to destroy those
people whether they're Donald Trump or
their Ron DeSantis regardless of who you
happen to like more at the moment and
there's other people as well and the
challenge is
for you to figure out how you can fight
alongside of them that was a Margaret
Thatcher impersonation by the way Brock
announced in the middle of that clip
that until three months ago he thought
that Margaret Thatcher was actually a
member of The Golden Girls so it's all
very confusing around here on that note
we've got a post game show for you at
reubenreport.locals.com in about 30
seconds we leave you with more gaffes
from the elderly man pretending to be
president see you tomorrow
that's why I had so damn many other
people I grew up have cancer and why
can't for the longest time Delaware had
the highest cancer rate in the nation
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
I was in the foot of foot excuse me
Mr Haney
we're doing it for the first time now in
the 20th 21st century going into the 20s
from the 20th century going into the
second quarter of the 21st century that
we'd say 12 years is enough I think 12
years enough and going into 20 30 40 50.
the rebuilding of uh of Syria of uh of
Libya you know this is they're there and
I want to thank the prime minister of
for Colombia's leadership and the
aseanazacion chair
thank you
[Music]